in boulder colorado investigation and
mourning
10 people murdered in a grocery store on
monday
detectives say a 21-year-old man is
responsible omar villafranca has the
latest
boulder police have identified the man
accused of killing 10
people at a supermarket on monday this
suspect has been identified as a mod
alyssa 21 of arvada he has been charged
with 10 counts of murder in the first
degree
police have identified all 10 victims
they range in age from 20
to 65. i wish i could stand here
and promise that the pain will heal
quickly it won't swat vehicles
hundreds of police officers and at least
three medical helicopters responded to
the scene
but the first was boulder police officer
eric talley
one of the 10 killed in the attack we
can never
thank officer talley or his family
enough for their sacrifice but we will
not forget it
inside the store ryan barosky told our
denver station kcnc tv
no one knew what was going on heard
you know one loud bang thought somebody
just dropped something an employee or
something and then another
and then by the third one everybody was
running he and others escaped through
the loading dock
so just at that point it was just run
get out of there tell everybody to leave
and yeah that's what we had to do
newlyweds nevin and quinlan sloan were
also inside when they heard the gunshots
i pushed up on the emergency door i
think we were the first to
to be out he said he helped people exit
from the back of the store
i was like dan this guy could like come
out and start shooting these guys i want
to make sure they're like as far away as
they can be stephen mchugh's son-in-law
and grandchildren were at the store's
pharmacy to get a covet vaccine
and hid for more than an hour the
shooter came in
shot the woman in front of them they had
ran upstairs or hiding in a coat closet
for the last
hour several people who had been
sheltering inside the king supers
were escorted out by officers half a
dozen
cops came in through the roof got him
and then
told them you know stay quiet and they
they're okay
with such a large crime scene it could
take days before they're able to fully
process the scene
omar via franca cbs news boulder
colorado
back here in nevada metro police sent
out their condolences to the boulder
community they put out this tweet
where the department saluted boulder
police and the life of the officer
killed officer talley